Ah see the screen. Okay, great.
All right, awesome. All right, let me introduce
you. Welcome to the DDP seminar everyone. Before
we introduce our invited speaker, let's go
over some rules and logistics. First of all,
please mute yourself during the talk. But if you
have questions, you can unmute and ask questions
were used chat room to post your questions so that
we can address them in q&a session at the end.
Second, today's DDPS seminar is open to external
audiences. Therefore no classified discussion
is allowed. Finally, the talk today will be
recorded and uploaded in our YouTube channel. Oh,
that's about it. Let me briefly introduce our
speaker today. It is an honor to host Dr. Alberto
Padovan who is a postdoctoral researcher in
the Department of Aerospace Engineering at
the University of Illinois Urbana Champaign. He
obtained his PhD from Princeton University in
August 2022. And His research interests lie at
the intersection of fluid mechanics, dynamical
systems and control theory. Alberto's current work
focuses on the development of data driven methods
for modal reduction of fluid flows, as well as
on the analysis and control of supersonic and
hypersonic wall bounded flows. Today, Alberto will
talk about data driven model reduction via non
intrusive optimization of projection operators and
reduce to the dynamics. I'm sure we are going to
hear a wonderful talk from him. Now let me ask a
somewhat informal questions to Alberto just to get
to know him better. Here we go. Are you ready?
Number two. All right. This is the best random
question I came up with. After I hearing about
your background. I happened to know you. You love
soccer. And if you can share your favorite soccer
player history in history, that sister in history,
their soccer player, I would say
Paolo Maldini was the CMR. Captain.
I'll go with them if I choose one. Yeah.
Do you have the reason?
Well, it was the it was the captain of
my favorite team for a long time. And I
guess he's known as one of the best defenders to
ever play the game. So yeah, that's why ready?
Great. Okay. Is stagey these is
yours. Alberto. What was that?
Stage is yours. It's your
presentation. Yeah. Okay.
Thank you, Dr. Troy for for inviting me
at the DDPS Seminar Series. Today we'll
talk about data driven model reduction, the non
intrusive optimization of projection operators,
and reduced order dynamics. And
here's a the outline of my talk,
I'll go over a few slides of introduction and
motivation. And I'm sure that most if not all
of you are familiar with some of the some of the
concepts I'll be talking about. Then I'll go over
an overview of some existing formulations,
we'll touch upon Petrov, Galerkin models,
which are intrusive. And then we'll talk about an
existing non intrusive formulation which is known
as operator inference. After that, I'll present
the main topic of this of this presentation,
which is Nystrom. This is a non intrusive
trajectory based optimization of reduced
order models, and is an extension of existing
methods that we've recently come up with. And
then I'll show some examples. We have three
examples of increasing complexity to model,
a one dimensional PDE and then a two dimensional
driven cavity flow. Okay, so even though I'm sure
that most of you are familiar with the overarching
idea of model reduction, I thought it'd be good
to set some foundations, just in case and, and so
physical systems that were interesting, interested
in studying or simulating, like fluids or solids
are described by partial differential equations.
And after spatial discretization we obtain systems
of ODS with many degrees of freedom. So here's a
brief example we have the incompressible navier
stokes equations. And after spatial discretization
using finite difference by volume finite element
you name in your favorite spatial discretization
scheme, we obtain a system of OD ease were here
for instance, you have sub d is the velocity on
a on a mesh and PDS the pressure and and q is
the is the spatially discretized state. So the
mainstay challenges associated with this high
dimensionality is computational cost. And this
can come in many flavors, but most notably, ones
the cost associated with integrating equation one
time. And number two could be related to the
curse of dimensionality during tasks such as
optimization control design, a system analysis.
So to reduce cost, we'd like to find a reduced
sort of model, which is a system given an equation
two, that behaves like equation one in some sense,
but it's much cheaper to work with. And the reason
why it's cheaper to work with is because the
reduced order model states Z has dimension that
is usually much lower than the dimension of q,
so we can integrate and work with equation two, in
a more computationally efficient manner. Alright,
so there are many approaches and many decades of
literature on model reduction for for physical
systems, but most of them tend to tend to share
this, this type of architecture that I'll discuss
in a second. So the first step is we start from
the, what we call the full order model or the
form. This is this especially discretize. Your
stokes equations, if you're working with fluids,
cubes, this is the state vector, it could be the
velocity, density, or any any flow variable you're
interested in. And you in case there's a there's
control input, for instance, could be a boundary
for saying the volumetric forcing, whatever type
of actuator control input you might have on your
on your system. So it reduced sort of model
can be described schematically, as follows,
we have three components, we have an encoder,
decoder and ROM dynamics. So the decoder upsI is
a awesomely nonlinear function that takes you
from the dimensional space onto a low dimensional
space, this could be a linear subspace or
a nonlinear manifold. And so basically,
this operation is that of a compression. So
we go from dimension to dimension. Once we're
in low dimensions, we have their own dynamics
that evolve the low dimensional state, in time.
And then finally, we have a decoder which goes
which spa is a possibly nonlinear map from the low
dimensional space to the high dimensional space,
and gives us this quantity Q hat, which is the
approximate solution Q. And hopefully, once we've
gone through this pipeline, Q hat is not so far
away from the ground truth solution Q. And as I
was saying, there are many different approaches to
to this and decades literature. So the encoder and
decoder could be linear, it could be nonlinear,
the encoder and decoder could be constrained
to the final projection. So where for instance,
the encoder is a left inverse of the decoder. And
so we are implicitly defining a projection. And
then also, it could be intrusive or non intrusive
in the sense that the computations that give us fi
MCI could be relying on the full order model or
it could be relying exclusively on data without
any knowledge of the governing equations that
generated the data itself. And then as far as the
route dynamics go, we could have continuous time
dynamics, discrete time dynamics, and again, they
could be computed intrusively, or non intrusively,
depending on the specific application. Alright,
so on today's talk, we're going to constrain
ourselves to encoder and decoders that are
linear. So they can be represented as n by
our matrices in this specific case, also,
we constrain them to define a linear projection.
So here, you see that the the encoder is the left
inverse of the decoder by design. And then also
the reduced order model dynamics are continuous
in time. And so today's overarching question is,
how do we learn Phebe psi and ROM dynamics G non
intrusively with the additional constraint than
fee upside to find an oblique projection? Alright,
so why don't we see some projections in the
first place. So as I said before, if the
encoder is the left inverse of the decoder, then
we're implicitly defining a projection operator,
which they call P. And if p is equal to Sy, then
the projection is orthogonal. And if they're not
equal, then the projection is oblique. So here's
a here's a schematic of what an orthogonal and
oblique projection to do. So if we have a three
dimensional vector q in three dimensional space,
and we have a target subspace, which is the
span of FY, then an orthogonal projection will
basically take you and projected onto FY in the
direction of the orthogonal complement of fee.
But if we want to have an oblique projection,
instead, we need an additional component,
which is another subspace sigh, I'm sorry,
another subspace, which is given by the span
of sigh. And so complete projection will take the
vector of Q and projected onto feet onto the span
of fee along the orthogonal complement of the span
upside. And so in general, we'd like projections,
because if, if the vector q lies in the range
of the project And then basically projection,
the projection operator p x is effectively the
identity operator operator on its range. And so
intuitively speaking from from the physical
standpoint, this means that the operation
of encoding and decoding the farm state does not
introduce the spirits drift in the wrong state. So
basically what we're saying if the wrong thing, if
the reduced amount of state is evolving, we want
it to be evolving because of the wrong dynamics,
not because of the of the operation of encoding
and decoding going from high dimensional low
dimensional space. So this is, loosely speaking,
the reason why we like projections. Now, why do
we like oblique projects. So, there's many reasons
why we, you know, going over all the reasons
why it would take a lot of time. But in general,
we need oblique projections for systems that are
commonly referred to as non normal. And so were,
loosely speaking, low energy states that
we might not be able to see in a simulation
are nonetheless dynamically important. And
so to capture those types of mechanisms,
we need oblique projections. So I thought I'd give
you an example of the reason why bleak projections
are good. So this is not quite an explanation
of why we need them, but more so evidence of the
fact that we do need them. So as a simple example,
here, we have a complex Ginzburg Landau equation,
we'll go back to description of it in a little
bit. But for now, the important thing is that
we have a one DPD. And we'd like to be able
to compute reduced sort of models that are,
that can predict the time history of the output
Y in response to some input here. So that's the
name of the game. So instead of solving this PDE,
we want in this specific case, five dimensional
reduced order models that can tell us what happens
to why as we forced the system with some unknown,
unseen MTU. And so I'll try to unpack unpack this
figure as best they can. So what we did here is we
forced the equation for with an impulse. So
we started from nonzero initial condition
in the span of be an initial time, and then we let
the simulation go, and we compute you, I'm sorry,
why. And so the ground truth, history of the
output y is given by the black line. And then
what we do here is we use four different model
reduction approaches to compute five dimensional
reduced order models. And I'll describe each one
of them in detail in a little bit. But for now,
the important thing is the following. So we have
the first two methods are one is intrusive, and
the other one is non intrusive. But the important
thing is that they both rely on orthogonal
projections onto a low dimensional subspace. The
bottom two are one is intrusive, the other one is
non intrusive, and it's the one I'll be talking
about mostly today. But the the most important
thing is that they compress the data using
oblique projections. And you see the striking
difference between the predicted capabilities of
models that use oblique projections over models
that use orthogonal projections, both models
using oblique projections are doing a great
job at tracking the ground truth history of the
output, whereas the models that rely on orthogonal
projections are not doing that great job. And
this is also true for a different type of input,
we're forcing with a sinusoid now, but the picture
remains qualitatively the same in the sense that
oblique projection ROMs are doing a good job of
tracking the output, whereas orthogonal projection
ROMs are not really giving us good prediction of
what happens to why in response to you. Alright,
so I hope this this was, I guess, convincing
evidence enough of the reason why we need oblique
projections for for model reduction. So here's
an overview of some existing formulations. So,
perhaps the most well known approach for to
obtain a reduced model is Petrov Galerkin. And so,
this is an intrusive approach. And computing
the reduced order model requires knowledge
and access to the full order governing equation
governing equations. So, if we have the if the
farm equations are given by equation five, this
again could be the or the specialty discretize
and average stokes equations, then the petro
Galerkin dynamics are given by equation six.
And what equation six is telling us that is that
we are constraining the state q to the range of
the projection for all times. And also, not only
are we projecting the state onto the range of p,
but we're also projecting the Dynamics F onto the
range of p. So, we obtained this this model that
is to be designed in such a way that Q hat
is as close as possible to the original the
original state q. And so even though the state q
hat in this specific way, have written and has the
same dimension of the state q, the dynamics and
six can be realized by a low dimensional system
where the dimension of the state z is that
of the rank of the projection. So we see that
basically The takeaway from this slide is that
Petro Galerkin model the degrees of freedom,
in particular can model so what we, what we get to
choose are the matrices Fiemme sigh. But once we
choose though those the round dynamics are fully
determined by flip side, and by the full order
Dynamics F. I'd like to point out that actually,
we don't need to specify Fiemme psi more so as the
their span. So really a natural delivery model
is not a function of of the matrices VM side, but
rather a function of this spaces that they span.
And we'll come back to that in a little bit. So
the name of so question is, how do we pick the up
side, there are different ways to do that. Perhaps
the most popular one is pod. Pod color coding
is that weekly truths of approach. And it's
historically the simplest way to choose fi upside.
In fact, it goes like this, we collect data from a
full order simulation, we stack it into a matrix
and we take SVD, then what we do is we retain the
first our columns of u, we call these the leading
our pod modes. And then we simply set fee equal
upside equal to the first our pod mounts.
Once we have feed, we can easily compute the
ROM dynamics as shown in bullet point three.
And so this implicitly defines an orthogonal
projection onto the range of the pod modes.
And the ROM is known as a Galerkin model. And
so from an intuitive standpoint, what we're doing
here is we are projecting the governing equations
onto the span of the most energetic features
of the system. However, as I discussed briefly,
few minutes ago, there might be non energetic
states that are dynamically relevant. So that's,
that's when we need a bleak projections. And
so a common way to get an oblique projection is
vast truncation. And so it was first developed
in 1981. So it's somewhat old formulation. And
it's a tool from linear control theory. And the
method is highly intrusive. And I'll describe it
in a minute what I mean by it. And so, bounce
Christic bass truncation proceeds as follows,
we start from the nonlinear governing equations.
And first step is we need to linearize about a
fixed point. So here a is the linearization of
f, which is the derivative of f with respect
to the state and the input matrix U A, B is the
derivative of f with respect to the control input.
And so now we have obtained we've we've obtained
a linear time invariant system, which we can work
with, with what we like LTI systems, because we
kind of know everything there is to know about LTI
systems and we can work with them pretty easily.
So the the name of the game in bounce Truncation
is the follows is the following, we want to
find and truncate a set of coordinates where
the controllability and observability gradients
are equal, and diagonals. Now the specific details
are not important. But basically, to find Fiemme
psi, we need to compute these integrals in the
parentheses. And you see that these integrals,
which are the grammarians depend on a and a star,
which is the Agilent way. And so in that sense,
this method is very intrusive, because we cannot
treat the solver as a black box, we have
to go into the solver, we have to linearize
it, and then we have to compete, it's agile. So
those are very intrusive operations. In any case,
once we have fee inside, we can compute, we can go
back to our nonlinear system, and we can obtain a
Petrov Galerkin representation of it as far as and
so as I was saying, this method is very intrusive,
because not only do we need to query F to compute
round dynamics, but we also need to access the
linearization and its Agilent around a steady
state. So that's an that's an exclusive. That's
an intrusive operation. The third approach I'll
be discussing today, really briefly, is there's
another formulation that we developed a couple
of years ago and it's called Truth is trajectory
based optimization of oblique projections. And it
produces a wrong as follows the the actual concept
is pretty straightforward. We collectors actually
data and we and we save it from from a full order
simulation. And then what we want to do is we want
to find subspaces v and w that define an oblique
projection that minimize this cost function, which
is just the mean square error between the ground
truth data and and the ROM prediction subject to
a Petro Galerkin model of this form. So remember
that, as I said before, a oblique projection is
not really a function of the upside, but it's
a function of the subspaces v and w that
they expand. So the optimization problem
is carried out in terms of the subspaces and
the appropriate optimization spaces to grasp
and manifold. And we'll we'll come back to
that in a second once we discuss Nitrome. But
the takeaway from this is this is an extremely
intrusive procedure. So if you want to compute
the gradient of the cost function with respect
to the subspaces, then you can sort of see how
we'll have to compute the linearization of f and
if agilely along and try the entire trajectory. So
the reduced order model is a function of fee and
psi, but these psi are fed into the CFD solver. So
if you want to compute gradients, we'll have
to differentiate the CFD solver. And that's,
it's extremely interesting. Okay, so enough
with intrusive methods, we'll move on to to one,
intrusive and non intrusive formulation, which is
operator inference, which is very much related to
to Nitrome, as we'll see in a second. So I'll
provide a brief description of it here. So as
we were saying, in petro dollar CAD models,
the only thing that we can choose RFEM side.
And then the round dynamics G are tied to the
form Dynamics F in purely data driven methods,
we can also choose G as a matter of fact, we're
forced to because data is the only thing that
we have to to back out g we cannot really access
the governing equations. And so operator inference
proceeds as follows. The first step is we collect
data from from a representative trajectory,
and we do pod and we we let VMs equal b equal
to pi equal to the pod run. So, we're implicitly
defining we're compressing the data from a high
dimensional space to the low dimensional space,
the orthogonal projection onto the span of pod
mounds. So the second step is the following. Well,
as I just said, we compress the data onto the span
pod mounds, and we get coefficients z, but we also
want to get the coefficients, we also want to get
the time rate of change of those coefficients. So
we we take the time derivative of the full or
state, and we project it onto the span of the
pod amounts. And so, assuming that the reduced
order dynamics are polynomial in form, so they
can be written as, as this equation here, operator
inference solves this least squares problem where
basically we want to find reduced order tensors
ah B and however many others that minimize the
difference between the round dynamics and the
time rate of change of the projection of the farm
state onto the pod mouse on on on the span of the
pod months. So basically, in operator inference,
we set the encoder decoder to be given by the pod
modes that defines an orthogonal projection. And
on the span of those nodes, we want to find
polynomial dynamics by fitting tensors. Okay,
great. So this is kind of the overview of the
methods that are inherently connected with with
nitrogen, which, which I'll be talking about in a
second, I'd like to point out that there are many
different other ways to to do model reduction, as
I said in the introduction, discrete time discrete
time dynamics, nonlinear encoder decoders, but
as far as we're concerned today, this is what
we will be comparing Nitrome against. So here
we go. So this is not interested in trajectory
based optimization of reduced the remodels. And
this method kind of brings together concepts both
from intrusive model and both and from operator
inference, but the beauty of it is that will we
will not need access to the governing equations
and we can do the optimization purely from data.
And so loosely speaking, is what we do is
we simultaneously and unobtrusively look
for optimal fields Sy and G given full order
trajectories. And so, this is the full order
model. Here again, this could be any specialty
discretize PDE, we have an initial condition
q naught. And then also we might be interested in
some observable y, this could be a pressure at a
wall could be shear stress could be the velocity
profile somewhere on your computational grid,
and then what we're looking for our reduced order
models of this form. So, we have the dynamics of
the rung evolving the coefficients on the span
of a projection that will be defined shortly. The
initial condition is the projection of the initial
condition of the farm onto the span of feed
and then we have the predicted output white hat.
And so, a couple of things, I want to I want to
discuss a couple of things before we lay we lay
down to the optimization problem in mathematical
terms. The first thing that we observe is that
the ROM is not a function of fee itself is a
function of the of the subspace that spanned by
c. And so in fact, you can it can be shown that
for any invertible matrix matrix, m of size R
by R, this relationship holds this means that,
if we stretch and rotate feet, we're not
changing the reduced order model. So, our
dimensional subspaces of Rn are elements of the
grasp and metaphor. And so we will be looking for
an optimal V on on the on the grasping manifold.
A similar symmetry does not hold for sigh. In fact
there exist invertible RBR matrices and where
equality where this equality doesn't hold so,
meaning that if we're if we rotate and stretch
sigh, we do change the reduced order model. And
so, the ROM is not a function of the span upside
but rather a function of sites of nonetheless,
we want site to have rank are otherwise we
wouldn't be able to define a production.
And so without loss of generality, we can take
site to be an element of the Stiefel manifold,
which is the space of orthonormal and by
RT matrices. And the third assumption will
be that the assumption we make next on the round
dynamics is that they are polynomial. So we kind
of borrowing this from operator inference
that we described a minute ago. And so yeah,
we're saying the polynomial dynamics are
polynomial, the rounded answer polynomial. So
the parameters we'll have to learn from data are
these tensors, a, H and B in red. So altogether,
the red quantities on this slide are the ones who
will be tried to fit will try to fit from data.
Okay, so mathematically, this is the optimization
problem. So we have ground truth observations
from the farm called y collected at some temporal
temporal instances TI, and then we have a reduced
order model of polynomial form, that will give
us a prediction y hat at the same at the same at
the same times. And what we want to do is want to
minimize this cost function by choosing a subspace
B on the Grassman manifold a a n by our matrix
sy on on the unstable manifold and reduced order
tensors that define the dynamics and so the
optimization is carried out on this product
manifold of the Grassman Stiefel and as many
linear spaces as the number of tensors that
we're trying to fit from data. Okay, so how
do we compute the gradient? So the trick is
that this manifold, and that we've just defined,
maybe it's best if I go back, it's an abstract
manifold. It's abstract in the sense that the
Grassman is a is a is a manifold of subspaces
and subspaces are abstract entities that we
cannot represent on a computer. The only way
we can represent the subspace fee on a computer is
indirectly through through fee and then v is equal
to the range of fixed so how do we how do we deal
with this abstraction? The way to do it is to work
to view the steeple and the grasp of manifolds as
sub manifolds of an ambient space, whose object
whose elements can be represented easily on a
computer so Stiefel can be viewed as an embedded
sub manifold of Euclidean space of matrices of
size and by art, and then if we define a metric
on this space, the stiff the Stiefel manifold
will inherit it. And the grasping manifold
can be viewed as a quotient manifold of the non
orthogonal Stiefel manifold. So these are these,
this is the space of n by our matrices of rank.
And so again, if we define the a metric a metric
on this space, then the Grassman manifold will
inherited. Once we've done that, it is possible
to define the grading of the cost function in
terms of Euclidean space objects. So for instance,
we can we can define the gradient of the cost
function with respect to with respect to the
substrate speed, in terms of in terms of fee and
so we can easily compute that on on a computer.
And so, the approach is quite standard, we have
our cost we use the method of Lagrange multipliers
with our cost function, we append the constraints,
and here lambda are there Lagrange multipliers,
it can be shown that these satisfy a reduced
order Agilent equations. And then once we once
we turn the crank, on calculus variations, it can
be shown that the gradients that the gradient of
the cost function with respect to the parameters
can be computed in close form. So for instance,
just to give you a sense of what this might look
like, the grading of Allah with respect to a looks
like this, right? And so you can think of and
the procedure that gives you the gradient, it's,
it's it's very much akin to a back propagation
when you're training neural networks. The I
guess the the beauty of the way we laid out the
problem is that the gradient of our quote unquote,
neural network, it can be computed in closed form,
and so we don't need automatic differentiation to
carry out this optimization. Alright, so I guess
it's time for for some results now. And we'll look
at three different examples toy model, a one DPD,
and a lead driven cavity flow. So the toy model
is a system of three ODS, it's very simple system.
With state x 1x 2x. Three, we have an input u. And
what we're interested in is in the time history
of the output Y in response to inputs here,
this new here is a parameter that we've introduced
to show the need for oblique projections versus
orthogonal projection. So if you take if new is
very small, or even new, or even equal to zero,
for the sake of discussion, the dynamics become
effectively linear. But most importantly,
they are governed by a diagonal, linear operator
diagonal operator, it's normal. And so we,
we expect that modern reduction approaches
that rely on orthogonal projections will give
us good reduced order models. Instead, if
new is large, the system is nonlinear, but,
but more importantly, the snom linearity
has a special feature. So we see that it
depends on x three. And so if you look at what
x three does, x three is the fastest decaying
state of the system. So in the case, well, its
dynamics are linear, and it decays with with
rate minus five. And so this x three is the least
energetic state of the system. But nonetheless,
it has a very large effect on the dynamics of
x 1x. Two. And so if new is large, of course,
so if new is large, we expect that we're going
to need oblique projections for model reduction.
Because we'll oblique projection is give us the
possibility of detecting the fact that low energy
states might be very important from from a
dynamical standpoint. Okay, so we consider
two different cases, new equal to five and new
equal to 20. And we train the models with four
step responses. So we'll, we'll we have a step
input, you, we put it into the dynamics and then
we collect the time time history of y in response
to this for these four steps. Just to be clear,
I'm not making a we're not computing a parametric
run as a function new, we're considering two
separate cases just to show when you may or may
not need a blink projections for model reduction.
So here, we're showing the average testing error
across 100 Step responses for new equal to five,
and here for new equal to 20. So we see that for
new equal to five, we've seen that the dynamics
are effectively linear and normal. So all model
reduction approaches, including those that use
orthogonal projections, namely pod, Eagle, arcing,
and operator inference, are doing pretty well,
the error is very, very low. And even though
we're improving on it with our formulation,
there's really no need for oblique projections
in this specific case. But if we, if we turn up
the value of New, then the dynamics become more
quote unquote, non normal, where the this low
energy state is becoming more data important. And
we see that the two model reduction formulations
that leverage leverage oblique projections are
performing significantly better than orthogonal
projection based reduced order models. And so
this is these are plots that are computed using
step responses. This is what we trained on. But
what about different types of inputs? So, here
we put in sinusoids. And so we didn't train our
sinusoids. And we hope that our that our training
has given us models that are capable of telling
us what happens in response to a different type
of input that we haven't seen before. So if new is
small, again, and dynamics are effectively normal,
we see that all modern production formulations
are doing are doing extremely well. There's no
distinction between between them, at least from
a qualitative standpoint. But then, if we if we
turn on if we turn up the value new, we start
seeing some some major discrepancies and we
see that Troopa Nitrome that reliably projections
are tracking The GroundTruth output very well. But
the other two formulations are not doing so good a
job as it can be seen from from this figure. Okay,
so this is this is all for the reduced order
model. We'll move on to a more complicated system,
you have already seen this briefly and in the
introductory section of the talk, but, so,
this is the complex Ginzburg Landau equation. So
this is a one dimensional PDE and where here new
gamma and mu and a our parameters, we choose them
so that the origin is linearly stable. The system
However, despite the fact that it's stable, it
will exhibit law For example, to transmit growth,
and this is this is due to the fact that the
linear operator here is not normal. And so again,
this is one of those instances where we'll need
whether we work intrusively or not exclusively,
we need to compress the data using oblique
projections. And so the just just just for
the sake of example, what we'd like to do is to be
able to predict outputs y in response to inputs,
B, Vu. And so here, in this figure, I'm showing
the spatial distribution of the input and output
operators B and C, here we have B, in black,
and C in red. And so from a physical standpoint,
we're we're forcing the system upstream. And we're
and we're observing the response downstream. And
this is this is typical of specially developing
flows, for instance, where of take a jet,
for instance, where you might actuate near the
nozzle, but then you want to look at what happens
to the to vorticity. downstream. And so this is
this is kind of what we're trying to, to emulate
here in this example, and we look for models
with dimension five, and we trained with four
impulse response impulse responses. So the spatial
distribution of the impulse is in the span of B,
what we what we what we bear is the amplitude of
the impulse magnitude, u at time zero. And so once
we train, then we test across 25 impulse responses
with unseen amplitudes. And here we have again,
pod Galerkin operator inference troop and our
formulation nitrogen. And we see that Nitrome
and troop for that matter, are doing very well
under their maintaining a very low average error
across time. And here on the right hand side
is a representative trajectory of the output Y,
taken from one of these impulses that we that we
tested on. So we see that both Troopa Nitrome are
capable of tracking the ground truth, time history
of the alpha y. But the other two formulations
with orthogonal projections are not really
capable of giving us a a faithful prediction
of what happens to the to the full order system in
response to input. And then just for just to make
sure that we've learned dynamics, and we haven't
overfit impulses, we we changed the, we changed
the forcing input. On the left hand side, we're
forcing with a sinusoidal input. With frequency
omega, this is roughly the natural frequency of
the full ordered dynamics. And we see that we're,
again, we're tracking the output pretty well.
And this is the analog for the second harmonic
of the fundamental frequency. And again, we see
that we're doing a pretty good job here as well,
can see some minor discrepancies here at later
time. This is probably due to the fact that the
frequency content to omega wasn't that dominant in
the training dataset. So the model hasn't really
seen a lot of two omega structures showing up in
the in in the training data set. So I guess that
the four things with frequency to omega are
somewhat out of distribution for nonetheless,
we're performing much better than the other
methods using orthogonal projections and much
better than an operator inference, which is nine
years old. Okay, so this is the last example
I'll be talking about. So this is the I guess,
the highest degree of complexity complexity,
we've considered this is a two dimensional
incompressible, literal Academy fluid Reynolds
number 8300. The top boundary of the domain
moves with horizontal velocity equal to one,
and we spatially discretize the matter stokes
equations with a finite difference scheme on 100
by 100 grid. So what we want to do here for the
sake of example, we want to want models that are
capable of predicting the whole velocity field so
the whole und velocity field on the whole domain,
in response to inputs that enter the flow
via spatially localized bodied forest that
is placed near the top right corner. So you can
envision this as being like a Gaussian spatial
profile that injects acts as a body force on the
momentum equation of the fluid. So what we do is
we train reduced order models of dimension 50
With seven impulse responses. And just to give
you a sense for how this flow behaves, I've
plotted the energy of the perturbation from
the from the training trajectories over time
and what I mean by birth rate perturbations,
these are flux equations about the steady state
that exists at Reynolds number at 300. So most
notably, what happens here is that after an
initial decay in energy, the energy spikes back
up at roughly at time equals five or six. And this
is, this is typical behavior of non neural systems
where there's transient energy growth, and in
this specific case, it's pretty high amplitude.
If the system was normal than the,
the energy wouldn't spike back up,
and it would, it would keep on decaying back to
zero. And also, I'd like to point out that this,
this figure also indicates that the system is
quite nonlinear because these, these lines are not
scalar multiples of each other. So if the dynamics
were linear, then the these, these will be scalar
multiples of each other, but they're not in this
case. So we're looking at a nonlinear system that
has underlying non normal like dynamics. Alright,
so we do not apply troops in this specific case,
because it's because it's very intrusive, but
what we consider a special Galerkin projection
operator and Franssen nitrosamines. So this is
the training error for the seven trajectories
training trajectories, we consider it and this
is the testing error for unseen impulses. And
we see that with nitrogen, we've managed to keep
the error pretty low, even at times before 10,
where we have that huge spike in energy in the
in the training trajectories and, and testing
trajectories, for that matter. So the question
we're asking next is, okay, we have a model that
performs pretty well on impulse on impulses.
How does it perform on unseen inputs, and so
as before, we forced the system sinusoidally. So
we consider we have six different runs. And we
consider harmonics of the frequency one point
25, and harmonics at the frequency one, these
are frequencies that are relevant for the full
order dynamics. And we see that in all settings,
we're doing a really good job of tracking the, the
energy, the evolution of the energy of the of the
perturbations. For as I said, for all for Austin
areas. In particular, I want to point out that at
long time, aside from crass minor discrepancies
in amplitude, we are, we're getting the right
phase of these oscillations. And also at early
times, we're we're doing very well at tracking the
initial growth of energy before the system settles
onto a onto onto a forced limit cycle. So this is
what snapshots from the solutions look like we
have top left the full order model this is grant
this is ground truth solution computed from CFD,
this is nitrogen. Again, these are 50 dimensional
models, operator inference and pod alerting,
you see that pure legal arcing and operator
inference are underestimating the, the magnitude
of the vorticity that arises in response to these
sinusoidal inputs. But also they're they're not
predicting the face correct. So if you look at
this blue vertical structure here, x equal to 0.5.
At the bottom of the cavity, you see that operator
inference and pod Galerkin predict structures
that are out of phase with that, that structure.
By contrast, Nystrom is doing a very good job at
predicting both the amplitude of the vorticity
field and the phase of vertical structures.
And here's another set of snapshots for a low
frequency forcing input. In this case, again,
Nitrome is capable of predicting a given a good
prediction of what happens to the flow by contrast
operator and for instant pod lurking or it seemed
to be overestimating the vertical structure or the
vertical, the magnitude of the vorticity. And they
are not giving a faithful representation, the type
of vertical structures that we see in response
to the input. Okay, so in conclusion, we have
introduced a novel nonintrusive model reduction
framework for systems that exhibit large amplitude
change and growth. And the key takeaway is that
we improve on existing non intrusive methods by
projecting the high dimensional data onto a low
dimensional subspace via oblique projection. And
that's the key the improvement here is that we're
capable of computing oblique projections
directly from data for for model reduction
for future work. Here we're considering linear
projections onto onto linear subspaces. But it
would be interesting to extend the formulation to
nonlinear projections onto polynomial manifolds.
And it will be fascinating to be able to do
so while keeping the while still being able to
compute the gradient in close form. And we'll have
to see if we're able to able to do that without
relying on automatic differentiation. Yeah, so
I'd like to acknowledge the contributions from my
collaborators and co authors, Blaine Ballmer and
Professor budoni At UC and professor but only is
my postdoc supervisor. And then of course, funding
from the National Science Foundation. Okay, well,
thank you for listening. And I'm
very happy to take any questions.
Thank you. Thank you so much for the
wonderful talk. Alberto. Great job. Okay,
let's have a q&a sessions. We do have a
question from the chat have been asked.
Thanks for the talk. It was very interesting.
Can you give us a more insight explanation
on how oblique projection performs
better than orthogonal projection?
Right, right. Yeah. So let me
see if I can, perhaps, okay, so
from a from, I guess from a, try to get an
answer from a physical but also mathematical
standpoint. So typically, when we do orthogonal
projections, we look at pod, and then we use
pod to do so and pod will take trajectories
and look, and we'll give you a projection
onto the features that are most energetic. So
for instance, in this simple toy model, pod
would tell you that the most energetic states
are x one and execute. And so we'd be performing,
and we'd be projecting with the reduced order
model of would be neglecting the state x three.
The trouble with that is that the state x
three even though it's, it's very low energy,
because it's the case very fast, it's extremely
dynamically important, because we see that
x three has a large impact on the energetic
structures. So we have a situation where we
have high energy structures, but their dynamics
is very much affected by low energy structures,
that procedures like pod would completely
disregard. So what an oblique projection lets
you do is it lets you identify the high energy
subspace. So that will, it will give you fi high
energy subspace. But it also lets the boss gives
you the possibility of choosing side and side can
be chosen in such a way that it accounts for
the fact that x three is dynamic, important.
So when you have an oblique projection, you have a
more degrees of freedom, if you will, you have the
subspace where you project onto, and you but you
also have a subspace that tells you the direction
along which to present. And so by doing that, you
you're capable of that that's loosely speaking,
why we projection operators tend to work
better than projection operators. Yeah. Right.
Thank you. Next question is by Gizelle. Why is the
error consistently higher? Near physical to zero,
for example, for slide 27? Across the board? Is
Yeah, can you go to seven? Is this due to the
increased complexity of the function at all your
times? It's diminishes later? Or is there another
factor contributing to this behavior that I might
be missing? What happens with? Where am I? What
happens with these models? If you extrapolate
two times, that you are mortal? Hadn't sin?
Right? Yeah. So there's two questions there,
I guess. The first one is why is the error
consistently higher at early times? Okay. So
basically, oblique in general, okay, so most,
most of the contribution to the cost function
error is due to the long time dynamics of the
system. So for instance, if you if you have a
limit cycle, for example, a good reduced order
model will be a model that gives you the correct
amplitude of the of the limit cycle oscillations
and the correct face. And so in order to do that,
it might not be necessary to minimize the error
at early times. What's important, is that the
wrong trajectory. And is in the correct phase
with the farm trajectory he wants to farm enters
the low dimensional subspace. So basically, it's
kind of it's kind of a feature. It's kind of a
it's kind of something that we have to live with,
like the initial condition that we are giving
that we are looking at might not be close to
the subspace that we're protecting, that we're
using for model reduction and work So with that,
what oblique projection has allowed us to do
is that over time, the wrong trajectory, and
the farm trajectory will approach each other and
will continue in a synchronized fashion. And so at
that point, the round will be very good and the
error will be very low. So that's kind of early
time errors is kind of something that there's not
much we can do about because the initial condition
might be far away from the low dimensional
subspace that we're considering for model
reduction. So I hope that answers the question.
Second question that we had that was extrapolating
the model perform for long times? Well, as
far as very well, I guess. So. In this case,
for the toy model, we've trained from zero to 10.
But we're testing the sinusoidal input is carried
out for 30 time units. And so it's three times the
temporal extension of the it's like three times
the length of the training data set. And the same
goes for the complex principal Landau equation
and the letter of inquiry flow. We we would hope
that it's kind of a it's important that models
are able to extrapolate in time. And the way to
guarantee that is to make sure that we're actually
learning good dynamics, and that we're not, of
course overfitting. Once, once we're confident
that the ROM is that the wrong dynamics and the
projection is good, then we tend to observe that
the model is very capable of extrapolating to
very long times that hadn't been seen before.
Yeah. Awesome. Well, follow on to that. I mean,
your examples are statistically periodic or
the deterministically. Periodic, right? If
so, if you are extrapolating time domains,
you have seen those data people. So it's you
are able to capture that using the soft spacey,
you trained with a overly crazy
projections and operator inference.
Yeah, I'd like to point out that yes or no, no,
in the sense that we don't train on periodic data,
we train on impulses. Right. So the type of
although the information contained within
those impulses is enough. Yeah, that the model
figures out that if you force sinusoidally,
you will induce a limit cycle and with a certain
frequency and amplitude. And so that's why it's
capable of giving good predictions for a long
time. Yeah. So yeah, I agree. Like, the model is,
at the end of the day, as for any other data
driven method? If if the input is, you know,
in distribution, then we expect it
to do well, if for some reason we
have inputs that were no signature on the
training data, then the model might fail.
Yeah. Totally agree. Any other questions?
I have a couple of questions. So
all right, so before I go to my question,
yes. The the recall, as to questions, he said,
very interesting talk. And his first question
is, do you have a follow ative estimate of
the time saving of nitrile wrong compared
to the farm in the example? So basically,
speed up is talking about right. And
second question is, which criterion
did you use to decide the dimension
of the reduce model? basis? Dimension?
Great question. For
the for the for the, for the last example, I
guess. Well, okay, so speed up goes. I haven't
computed it, but for this example we have. Okay,
so this would be to flow variables. It will
be 20,000 dimensional, if I'm not mistaken.
So 20,000 degrees of freedom versus 50. Or no,
you do the math 1000 times faster. Roughly,
depending on Yeah, it's, yeah, it's quite a
bit faster. And, um, as far as the other okay,
what why did you, how did you pick the dimension?
Okay, so I picked the dimension by doing pod
first and looking at the decay of the singular
values of the training of the training data set,
and the leading 50 modes, gave us a Uh, forget
like roughly 99% of the total variance in the in
the data. So that's that's a very common criterion
to to pick the underlying wrong dimension.
Yeah. All right. Thank you.
Can you tell us? Does it make
sense to test this approach on chaotic
equation such as the Lorentz system?
That's, that's fantastic question. There might be
a little bit of difficulties
with that, in that, okay.
Let's see.
It might, it might make sense to do
it, I would actually be very curious
to see what happens. But what needs to
be careful when computing the gradient,
right? Because for when we're computing the,
we're integrating the ROM adjuncts equation
in time. So in effect, we were back propagating
the earth through the through the trajectories,
if the system is chaotic, then then the grading
would blow up. So there are I'm not too familiar
with literature on how to handle that. But I
know there are ways to optimize systems of,
you know, in the presence of chaos, so one
might need to do a little bit of trickery to
to be able to carry out the optimization.
But yeah, in, in principle, yes. I would
believe that it would make sense to, to look to
apply this formulation to chaotic systems. Yeah.
Thank you. So going back to my questions, my first
question is kind of related to what diesel asked
earlier, about, you know, all your times you got
higher error and example, you know, to eat a trip
and cavity problems, it clearly has a high energy
phase, and later on that energy dies dies out. So
the, for the touch to a problem, if you if I have
to divide the simulation into two phase, you know,
there's all the phase and later phase, there's a
concept called the time windowing, the ROM where
you can, you know, come up with a different set
of the bases for the four different phase. So,
in the beginning phase, you, you know, tailor
your basis so that it can capture the high energy
better. And then later on the, you know, it's
easier problems. So you probably get away with
a smaller dimension of the bases. So I think
you could extend your algorithm to time in
doing framework to even further improve the this I
did, relatively early in the only time face. Yeah.
That's, that's very interesting thought.
Yeah. So I guess that that approach would
let us maybe decrease the initial
initial error due to the fact that
the the initial condition is far away
from the subspace we're projecting onto,
but then we move on to a different subspace
later on that, yeah, it's a great thought.
And, yeah, I mean, there's a more discussion on
to it. But yes, that's the basic idea. And when
you go from one phase to another phase, you could
come up with a some sort of physics indicator,
depending on the applications. So that that
indicator tells you automatically where to change
it from, you know, first phase to the second
baseball scores if you don't want to manually,
you know, cut this time. So yeah. My second
question is, okay, you have presented in the
context of the reproductive case only. And natural
next step would be the parameterization. Like the
generalization OBO methods, if you can share any
thought on that, because that's natural next step.
Right, right. Yeah. So if we want to have
parametric, reduced order models, I guess that
what if I had to think about it really quick
how to do it would be to interpolate across
and parameter space. And of course, we'd have to
be we'd have to be careful about how we do that,
because we're like at each each parameter
where we actually perform a fit, we are
computing subspaces, and elements of Stiefel
manifold. And so we have to interpolate on those
manifolds and also, we'd have to get At that
the interpolated at once. Once we interpolate,
we preserve the property that fee upside to find
the final projection. Yeah. So I guess that those
would be the first concerns. Yeah. But it's very,
very much the next step on on how to extend,
and I welcome any sort of input. You guys
are all experts in these topics. Yeah. So
there is a interpolation and stuff on manifolds.
There's an acronym for that. So I can definitely,
definitely share that with you. Yeah, but yeah,
I totally agree. You know, interpolation would
be a way to go. Or the parameterizations. Awesome.
Okay. Um, all right. Is there any other question?
If not, let's thank our speaker, for the
wonderful talk so much, Alberto. Very much.
Thank you for joining.
Very nice work. And after this talk, hopefully,
there will be more collaboration
between Lawrence Livermore and your,
your I would love that.
Let's let's let's keep in touch.
All right. Sounds good. Okay,
thanks for having me again. Bye. Bye. Thank you.